Imagine a mad scientist
who is trying to create an artificial being
indistinguishable from a human
and early in the development of this machine,
he asks you for help testing the mind.
And so he confines the mind to a box.
The only way it can interact with the world
is by reading input messages and responding
by printing output messages.
And he presents you with the following challenge,
he shows you two identical boxes:
the other is connected to a human being
typing the output messages.
And you are allowed to ask the boxes
any sequence of questions you can imagine.
Do you think you could distinguish the machine
from the human?
What would you ask?
A triumph of mathematical and mechanical skill,
is this great new automatic calculator
at Harvard University.
Intricate problems in mathematics
put through the machine in coded form
on tape are accurately solved
in a minute fraction of the time
required for a human calculation.
In the first half of the twentieth century
general purpose computers
were only just emerging.
But speculations were swirling
about what would or
wouldn't be possible in the near future
with robots or intelligent machines.
It was a time when many human tasks
were quickly being swallowed  up by machines.
People feared powerful industrialists
would soon be supported by great machines.
Machines which could do anything.
Resulting in a class of poor labourers
who would simply toil away
to power the machines.
In nineteen-fifty, Alan Turing wanted to ground
these speculations about machine intelligence
using a scientific approach
known as a Turing Test.
Where a successful pass would mean
unequivocally that whatever is in the box
could be identified as intelligent.
And to this day,
no machine has been able to accurately
mimic conversation over long periods of time.
Historically, the concept of knowledge
and answering questions
have always been intertwined.
Across many cultures, there is a
deep rooted belief
that the source of all knowledge
comes from a higher power.
And one way to access knowledge
from a higher power is by posing questions
and waiting for a sign.
In ancient Greece, citizens could take their
toughest questions: usually key decisions
in social and political life
to a medium
who would enter a special location
known as an oracle.
For example the medium Pythia from Delphi
would enter the Sanctuary of Apollo
ask her question,
fall into a trance-like state,
and emerge with the answer.
Turing referenced this history
with his imaginary oracle machine.
Inside his oracle machine
would be access to an oracle database:
a database which contained
all answers to all questions.
In one column there is a list of all possible sentences,
think of this as our question column,
and many of these sentences would be meaningless but
every question you can think of
is in this book.
And in a second column: the corresponding answers.
If a machine had this oracle database,
it would be able to answer any question.
But could Turing's oracle machine
exist in the physical world?
Well the question column alone
would contain every possible
combinatoin of English words.
Even if we limit ourselves to all possible
twelve word sequences,
that results in 10 to the power of 72
different sentences.
Now even if you shrunk every letter
down to the size of an atom,
you would still end up with a book
larger than the size of the visible universe.
So the oracle database cannot exist.
When we store knowledge this way,
by simply memorizing facts,
we call this declarative knowledge.
For instance memorizing your multiplication tables
is declarative knowledge.
Music boxes can be said to 'know' a song
declaratively.
The music-roll declares each note.
This works well with small numbers
or short songs, but as the numbers get larger
and songs get longer you, will eventually
run out of memory.
So if a machine only knows declaratively,
meaning it memorizes everything,
then there is a very real physical limitation:
space.
So if a machine is passing a Turing Test,
we know it can't simply be memorizing
all possible answers.
It must be taking advantage of another
kind of knowledge.
It must know how to know.
Meaning it goes through a process
to get an answer.
For example knowing the rules of multiplication
or knowing how to compose new music.
And this kind of knowledge,
known as procedural knowledge,
is the focus of computer science.
How do things become known?
(Joe Fowler)